mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wer kultur
swisslos team viel vergnügen
[Applaus]
heute wird der kulturplatz eine wohltat
für die augen verloren und mein schritt
tyler der wird auch zufrieden sein denn
wir spazieren die einzige alternative
momentan zum daheimbleiben und das gute
daran spazieren ordnet die gedanken in
schwierigen zeiten
im weiteren werden wir den bau korn
konzert einer großartigen songs sängerin
lauschen und weitere kreative köpfe
treffen ist nicht zynisch finden diese
krise auch als chance zu nutzen zum
beispiel peter stand der schweizer
schriftsteller erzählt schein war so
einfach vom leben das wir herbeisehnen
erinnern oder ganz einfach auch
verpassen
das suter mit figuren die oft ergreifend
nah an uns selbst sind peter stamm lesen
das bedeutet immer auch in sich selbst
zu lesen
nun führt der preisgekrönte autor in
diesen tagen ein öffentliches corona
tagebuch
[Musik]
damit ist abgeriegelt der zürcher
seebecken peter stauber alles ist anders
wir sind in bestimmten teilen kommen
schrieb die texte aber ab rückgang schon
weniger rosig aus büroräumen haben sie
wohnen jetzt sagen wir gar eine kamera
stellten derweil eigentlich ist aber die
einsamkeit der schriftsteller so wie man
sich das so vorstellt anderes sicher
nicht fehlen
ja es gab natürlich mit einer weiten
reise ich weniger schrieben wenn die
anderen drei sind und irgendwie jetzt wo
alles so leif listmann zweimal
ländlichen wirtschaft wieder
beim spazieren airline aussicht stelle
lag man auch vor allem klassiker
kletterspinne die aussicht mit der alles
ab sagt ich sage mir entscheidend helfen
sie uns im vorstand ich hab ich ihn rufe
auto risches wesentlich mehr ist von 67
sehr vielen das bundesamt strukturen der
208 millionen franken gesprochen
für die kulturschaffenden wie sie schon
in wellenform motto wir sie entschädigen
drei oder vier jungs ob ich mich da
überhaupt und wie wir bei sind einige
sichere 512 14 leicht sind aber es ist
halt eine komplizierte hilfe marca
verträgt das ist alles informell man
macht mal machten die leistung konnte
skoda mit dem geld über das wird relativ
schwierig sie für kolleginnen und
kollegen zum detail wirklich nah wie ist
das was sie von uns fallen ja bald wird
der bundesrat entscheiden in richtig
locker weg 7 möglich ist das in ihrem
sind sie froh dass aber nicht normale
doch ich glaube schon aber letztendlich
expert entscheidet eine gewisse da nicht
es geht jetzt ganz viel exakter
plötzlich aber ich bin schockiert dass
diego für karstadt entscheiden
das einzigste was ist das für ein
prozess was bedeutete dies führt bei
langsamen prozesse zurück in die
normalität
und das ist schlecht diese maschine
heute alte aber nicht habe nicht einfach
wieder vor allem moment auf 301 langsam
wieder in gang
jetzt gehen mehrere mitarbeiter noch
immer über ihre veröffentlichten
tagebuch corona dafür brauchen sie einen
tag ihrer suche da es aber zum
picknickplatz und bis wir da sind können
sie sich der betreiber von meiner
kollegin sandra stefan über den balkon
über die wichtigkeit von balkonen tag
und zwar nicht nur für sonne und wer
hätte das gedacht dass ausgerechnet
diese paar quadratmeter unser tor zur
welt werden unser xanadu unser garten
eden unser wunderland in der krise liegt
unser aller balkon eine beispiellose
karriere hin
vom bloßen anhängsel zum angebeteten
sehnsuchtsort sehr zur freude von
kawamata der professor für geschichte
des städtebaus an der eth zürich
beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit balkon
jetzt wo er in den eigenen vier wänden
in antwerpen festsetzt nutzt er sein
kleines außen reich für ein gespräch von
balkon zu balkon über 600 kilometer
hinweg per skype
wie ist das wetter auf dem balkon alles
okay auf dem balkon nur jetzt fährt
gerade ein auto vorbei warum
interessieren denn forscher ausgerechnet
balkon
es ist ein sehr faszinierendes element
weil es verschiedene räume verbindet
privat und öffentlich individuell und
gemeinschaft den heimischen und den
städtischen raum auf dem balkon kehren
die menschen ihr inneres nach draußen
sie sind dabei aber nicht mittendrin
so können sie mit abstand und gefahrlos
kommunizieren oder für das medizinische
personal gemeinsam applaudieren die neu
bespielten räume beflügeln thoma formate
2014 hat er mit dem architekten star im
kohlhaas ein historisches buch über
balkone geschrieben jetzt will er wissen
was spielt sich auf ihnen während des
lok down weltweit ab unter dem hashtag
weinbergen sammelt er auf instagram
schnappschüsse
das echo ist groß die vielfalt
überraschend was als erstes an all
diesen bildern aus aller welt auffällt
ist dass den menschen unglaublich
erfinderisch sind in der nutzung des
begriffs dass sie neu für ganz
verschiedene aufgaben in ihren alltag
ein
die privaten außenräume werden zu
kleinkunstbühnen zu orten der begegnung
und des betens was denn forscher
besonders beeindruckt das kraftwerk
marke eigenbau nicht nur dass viele
balkone werden plötzlich zu politischen
mini schauplätzen einzelne flocken
verbinden sich dabei zu einer
gemeinsamen botschaft halte durch
und seid solidarisch weit vor corona
waren balkone plattformen großer
politischer ereignisse für evita peron
ansprachen an das argentinische volk
etwa oder für benito mussolini es
politische hetze gegen die gebete des
papstes hoch über den markusplatz und
die berühmteste liebesszene der welt
auch sie sind ohne balkon undenkbar und
selbst für leibesübungen ist er geeignet
einer rannte darauf einen marathon 6000
mal hin und her
und seniorinnen turnen auf ihren
balkonen gegen das virus an tom
aromatisch corona forschungen stehen
erst am anfang
schon jetzt aber wird klar der balkon
zeigt über die krise hinaus großes
potenzial
wir brauchen räume in denen wir uns
einen moment vom extrem geschäftigen
stadt leben zurückziehen können alleine
zu sein trotzdem teil der stadt
das kann aber kunden er hilft zu
klimatologischen und viralen
herausforderungen zu trotzen und dem
dichter hessen den städten
entgegenzutreten
ferien auf balkonien
die waren früher verpönt doch heute
spielt hier das leben pandemie konform
und fröhlich
[Musik]
peter stamm spazieren die möglich
spaziere ich sagen dass ich alle fasst
die wichtigsten
dreister dritter 2020 mein problem ist
dass ich zwar gerne ein tagebuch
geschrieben haben möchte aber dass ich
es ungern schreibe weil es mich schnell
zu langweilen beginnt meine tage zu
beschreiben ich habe es immer wieder
versucht am besten klappt es auf reisen
dezember quasi offene balkontür offen
linderhof und historischer platz später
starb sie schwebe der korona tagebuch
internet und zu schweben das ist
eigentlich lieder geschrieben hast
trotzdem ich bin gerade worden und das
ist helmer mirka tagebuchschreiber www
moxa bin ich nicht so spannend aber
wieso nicht die spezielle situation
ich habe meine frau ist zum beispiel
tagebuch geschrieben und das ist mir
schon schön wenn man sich nachher immer
genau was hat sie für ihren ausspruch
wenn sie das tagebuchschreiben ist ein
stück literatur
nein also so black spielt sollte daraus
ich bin nicht dass ein tagebucheintrag
muss sie wie einen literarisch das wäre
gehabt welche euro classic car built und
es wird schnell erholt und das
keineswegs dass blut java spricht ich
dass es wirklich im moment passiert und
und dann aber wieder hektisch 22
vertreter 2020 am ehesten könnte man das
gefühl als ein rezept beschreiben man
nehme etwas sorge etwas nervosität etwas
verwunderung ziemlich viel unruhe ein
paar vorahnungen unentschlossenheit
antriebslosigkeit und doch auch eine
prise zuversicht das gefühl kommt und
geht in wellen einig thriller lhasa
ihres darüber schließlich humor
ernsthaftigkeit auch um sich geradezu
verschiedene teile je nach material ist
hat sich jeder zustand verantwortlich
eine woche nach russland so gesehen dass
ich definitiv beruhigen die erste woche
ist nicht schwierig sie als richtung die
umstellung und hat die unsicherheit und
je länger das beste make will man sich
eigene sitzt da und desto weniger lang
gab es natürlich auch egal wie lange es
ist
weniger einig eine einigung gesetzt und
ist wieder auf und vor dem tagebuch die
ein mann show zeigen ihre special die
krise die anderes gegenteil ihres
schlechtesten bewertet da es nachhaltig
für andere durch die krone
ja ich bin immer der expo 2000 nach
nagellack seiten das ist 476 ich
natürlich werde ich nervös ist apa damit
dass das gesellschaftsvermögen andré sie
wird einfach menschen sind relativ
stabil und das ist gut so aber ins
crysis ach ja durchaus gehabt wo man
anders machen
flug zum beispiel ist es beispiel wenn
man sieht wie wenig flüge eigentlich
hoffen war nötig sind
und dann wäre da sind auch schon ideen
zum klimaschutz klimakrise viele größere
krise als die korona krise wirklich
ernsthaftes machen
er soll er ist der zürcher himmel
wahrscheinlich noch nie existieren kann
also sicher nicht gewählt dass sich apps
wird für andere schöne wofür ich dann
auch ein neues status gibt dass man sich
nicht nötig dass man immer alles buch
das eine art von verzichtet er bewusst
wählt konsumverzicht verzicht auf den
nächsten flug
es wäre schön sehr schön aber aber
jährlich 70 meter einfach aufgrund von
höheren alter relativ viel viel krise
bleibt und sich eigentlich immer gleich
die erste mal dass werber haben das
schöne am schluss doch wie freundlich
bevor sind sie realität pessimist
realismus abgemischt dabei aber trotzdem
danke spaziergang nicht was haben sie
denn da und jetzt muss ein sieg das ist
brune ries und zu geht die heute morgen
auch gekocht
26 vertreter 2020 es wäre eine gute
gelegenheit vogelstimmen zu lernen dann
hört sie besser jetzt wo die stadt
ruhiger geworden ist
auch ich bin ruhiger geworden habe wie
ich an den langsameren rhythmus gewöhnt
und eigentlich ist mein leben sonst ja
auch nicht viel aufregender das langsame
schreiben das nachdenken die
spaziergänge ich habe meine wege in die
aussenquartiere verlegt dort sind
weniger leute unterwegs als im wald wo
jetzt alle spazieren
[Musik]
so leer gefegt habe ich die zürcher
bahnhofstrasse noch nie gesehen die
luxusmeile versinkt in der stille der
vielleicht lernen tatsächlich dass wir
nicht permanent alles zur verfügung
haben müssen
[Musik]
jetzt zum sachbuch der stunde der
historiker rutka brechmann kommt zu
einsicht dass wir menschen im grunde
keine bestien oder welt zerstörer sind
sondern im grunde gut ob er damit recht
hat edward r ist der mensch wirklich gut
voller mitgefühl ein soziales wesen
diese bilder erzählen vom gegenteil von
nod dunklen abgründen vom krieg man
bekommt sie nicht aus dem kopf wenn man
dieses buch liest petra brockmann im
grunde gut sie bleiben wie ein schatten
wie ein kochender zweifel
wir wollen mit ultra brechmann über sein
buch und diesen zwiespalt reden
doch das sah skoff 2 virus beeinflusst
auch das leben im niederländischen
utrecht
die fragen stellen wir über skype
niederländische kollegen vor ort drehen
das gespräch obwohl die korona krise
nicht nur das gute im menschen
hervorbringt sondern auch nationale
egoismen will rüther brechmann mit den
zynischen theorien aufräumen
die der mensch nur als wolf im
schafspelz sehen wollen es ist
vielleicht ein zufall aber die jetzige
corona krise ist eher wie ein stresstest
für die these des buches korea sehr
sogar
meine theorie wird gerade getestet was
gerade geschnitten hat mich sehr an die
reaktion nach naturkatastrophen
es scheint dass krisen wirklich das
beste des menschen hervorbringen
petra brockmann ist nicht naiv
er weiß dass es leere regale in
supermärkten gab dass kaum jemand an die
flüchtlinge in griechenland denkt doch
ihn stört dass negative menschenbild in
unserem denken in den medien beim world
economic forum letztes jahr in davos
wurde er zum superstar
als er vor den superreichen schlichtweg
eine gerechte besteuerung ihrer vermögen
forderte hickel noch lange über
menschenfreundliche thurk r mit leben
und wohnen nochmals einladen
aber eigentlich sollten wir über steuern
alles andere ist doch schwachsinn
ruprecht manns thesen provozieren auf
ganz andere weise der mensch im grunde
brechmann verweist auf studien die das
verhalten der menschen bei
naturkatastrophen wie dem hurrikan
katrina der 2005 new orleans überflutete
analysieren die bilder zeigen menschen
die einander helfen die medienberichte
fokussierten aber auf etwas anderes
die nachrichten damals waren voll von
schlechtem von plünderungen und
vergewaltigungen
danach recherchierten soziologen und
anthropologen gründlich und fanden
heraus dass sich die meisten menschen
massiv geholfen
und um ehrlich zu sein genau das
geschieht auch in der jetzigen krise
vielleicht ist die korona krise noch zu
jungen die sozialen und ökonomischen
folgen noch nicht abschätzbar um dies
endgültig zu beurteilen
doch woher nimmt röther brechmann diesen
radikal anderen blick auf die spezies
mensch
er geht weit zurück in die geschichte
an die anfänge und fragt welche
eigenschaften haben dazu beigetragen
dass der urmensch überleben konnten als
stärke kampfbereitschaft nein
jüngste forschungen zeigen dass der
freundliche überlebte der jäger und
sammler aufgrund seiner sozialen
kompetenzen
doch dann beginnt der bruch der jäger
und sammler will besitz gründet städte
will erobern
eine zivilisation des stärkeren
entwickelt sich
die andere kulturen vernichtet in der
geschichte der westlichen kultur findet
sich diese idee erst die meisten
menschen im tiefsten inneren egoistisch
sind die biologen nennen das die
fassaden theorie der menschlichen natur
die zivilisation ist nur eine dünne
fassade sobald an den naturkatastrophen
kriege oder ein unglück geschieht
verwandelt sich jeder in eine besten
ich wollte die quellen für diese
fassaden theorie untersuchen film und
literatur zelebrieren diese theorie jede
dunkle kammer der menschlichen seele
wird genussvoll ausgeleuchtet ein
berühmtes beispiel william goldings herr
der fliegen millionen kinder mussten die
geschichte der schulklasse lesen die
nach einem flugzeugabsturz auf einer
einsamen insel strand was friedvoll
beginnt endet in anarchie ihren macht
der mensch als monster
ich habe mich gefragt ist das jemals
passiert was wirklich geschah deshalb
habe ich nach einem echten fall gesucht
und einen gefunden
von einer inselgruppe bei australien
erlitten sechs kinder schiff blut und
strandeten auf einer insel namens at sie
leben dort 15 monate und sind immer noch
beste für eine es zeigte sich dass die
wirkliche herr der fliegen version eine
geschichte von zusammenarbeit und
freundschaft ist
das ist zwar keine wissenschaftliche
untersuchung aber wenn schon millionen
immer noch die fiktive herr der fliegen
geschichte lesen müssen dann sollten wir
ihnen auch erzählen was in der wahren
geschichte geschah nämlich das komplette
gegenteil ultra brechmann thesen sind
verführerisch man möchte so gerne
zustimmen und sagen ja der mensch ist
gut wenn da nicht diese bilder wären
folter
auschwitz
die not von flüchtlingen warum schauen
wir weg warum grenzen wir menschen aus
und agieren unmenschlich wenn es um zu
einer spezies gehört die freundlich sein
will dann will man teil einer gruppe
sein und nicht gegen diese gruppe das
kann man ihn kriegen beobachten das
gruppengefühl wird so mächtig die leute
wollen so sehr zur gruppe gehören und
alles für diese gruppe tun dass sie
bereit sind völlig unmoralisch zu
handeln
demgegenüber die weit außerhalb der
gruppe stehen
aber das ist nur der anfang an bord es
ist wirklich nur ein anfang
rothmanns buch bietet mehr an
erklärungen mehr an visionen
er will dass wir ein neues menschenbild
sehen
eines das realistisch ist sich am
machbaren orientiert an bildern wie
diesen
[Musik]
also mein schriftseller ist inzwischen
bei 6.700 18 es kommen noch einige dazu
ich machen jetzt gleich auf den weg nach
wie die kohle und dort werde ich die
künstlerin veronika sparrenburg treffen
sie ist dabei bei uns am experiment
sieben künstlerinnen und ein virus und
bissig bei ankommen können sie sich
gleich die aktuelle folge anschauen
zürich bei nacht
der blick von drinnen aus der quarantäne
macht draußen die künstlerin veronika
spiegelburg hat dieses video gedreht die
liebe in zeiten von corona lieblingslied
von der nachbarschaft gesammelt und die
auf dem balkon bietet gespielt er sieht
sich als anders neues stadtbild kreiert
auf der straße und merkt sound und musik
verbindet enorm
veronika spielen burg ist eine von
sieben künstlerinnen und künstlern die
in diesen wochen ihre beobachtungen mit
uns teilen
ich heiße hamburg und die unvermutete
stille die sich über unsere welt gelegt
hat und rasiert veronika spiegelburg für
ein zukünftiges kunstprojekt auf der
welt was für situativ israelis sind die
städte verhandeln wir sprechen steht zu
uns passt die statischen schotten
professionelle tontechnikerin auf der
ganzen welt eingeführt um ihre stadt
sein dürften
es wird das digital sound archiv
metaphorisch ist die arbeit der liebe
gestehen krieg mit dir wo man vorher
nicht gehört hat
[Musik]
mehr als vier wochen shuttle vier wochen
quarantäne in denen die tänzerin lisa
horn skill bray zu hause arbeitet die
zeit wird langsam schiebt uns dieses
video viele emotionen wirbeln es bricht
mir das herz
ich fühle mit all den menschen die
leiden mit jedem der einen geliebten
menschen verloren hat
mit jedem der angst hat angst ich weine
ich will helfen und vermisse meine
familie
ja wir suchen die ganze zeit den ausgang
um dann weiterzumachen wie vorher
mein name ist uta köbernick und ich bin
kabarettistin schauspielerin und mache
die das ziel sondern solidarität so spät
ich suche eigentlich gar keine ausgang
sondern einen eingang einen eingang ins
freie
ins freie trotz corona trotz der absolut
nötigen maßnahmen und ich denke für uns
bühnenschaffen wird wahrscheinlich nicht
so schnell eine lockerung in sicht sein
aber ich möchte das nutzen
irgendwie wirft mich diese situation
eigentlich auf den kern der arbeit
zurück die gefahr ist jetzt dass ich
einfach ein video nach dem anderen
raushauen und dann gratis das netz zur
mühle und ich glaube ich sollte dieser
verlockung widerstehen
denn menschen gratis dann auch wirklich
arbeiten und nicht produzieren die krise
begreifen das ist arbeit sie auch
künstlerisch zu begreifen und das
braucht zeit
ein haltbares zu schaffen etwas was die
nächste schlagzeile überlebt und im
grunde sollte das eigentlich immer so
sein aber in dieser zeit wird ein bloß
noch deutlicher bewusst
und dieses bewusst werden dass im grunde
auch schon mal eine art eingang
jedenfalls eine tür die aufgeht wenn
auch nur im kopf
[Musik]
zum schluss ein gedicht von uta
köbernick die bürger mit langen grünen
strähnen der wind bewegt sie hin und her
im haus steht ratlos mit föhn in der
hand ein arbeitsloser friseur drinnen da
warten stehend die stunden nichts tun
und alles aber nicht mehr
wir sind ja so schlau und so wachsam und
klug erst hinterher ein kind senkt die
fab schwere pinsel spitze ins wasserglas
zack es rötet sich sehr
im gleichen moment taucht irgendwo die
abendsonne ins meer
[Musik]
nächsten mittwoch episode 4
mit musik und dem schauspieler andrea
zogg
da man diese clique der ersatzlose
willkommen
ihr bliebe nichts und
[Musik]
und risikogruppen sieht wirklich nicht
denn ist natürlich die wahl zurück die
die normalität noch viel dicker ist als
dass sie und das ist am anfang ganz
komisch sie will das oster ist plötzlich
ein einfaches werkzeug aachen als
schaffenswerk zögerer filmschaffen
befähigung reise ständig unterwegs und
ethisch gottes passiert das erzwungene
aus das haben sie sich allerdings klasse
was wünschen sie sich für nachkommen
was ich mir wünsche ja die projekt und
ich immer spiele machen dass ich dich
machen das dritte mal eine andere um
finanzielle unterstützung nicht markt
orientiert ist
[Musik]
die spaziere ist über in zürichs westen
der schritt schneller momentan bei 9
1484 schritten ist ja und drüben
erwartet uns ein erstklassiges balkon
konzert von der soul sängerin brandy
butler zusammen mit musiker mache es
ganz kurz
der hauseigene format entwickelt in der
korona kritisch us-armee aus dem thomas
bucher krise als chance nutze gemacht
und seiner erfahrung das sind jungs
bauer und terrestrischen am sonntag
genau jeden singer songwriter singer
songwriterin und erzähle der bitte bis
dazu und handel das einfach so den
versuch zu machen aber das persönliches
also sind als erster in der liga oder
was verbindet alles überhaupt mit ihrem
mann schwer gut präsentiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mag
hier läuft das konzert das ist das ende
unseres spaziergangs zu zeiten von
corona nächste woche übernimmt hier
meine kollegin nina may wies bruno sie
geht der frage nach wie die welt
aussehen kann
nach der krise gleich gehts weiter auf
sf1 mit der schweizer serie kleine lügen
wir sehen uns bald wieder bleiben sie
gesund und genießen sie denn so von
balkonien
das mache ich jetzt auch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur